[Musique]
moi c'est un produit à base de cire et
d'essence et lycée aussi pour entretenir
mais pas que allez viens voir ça
bonjour
c'est le mot plancher
plancher mais ça passe en costume
et ensuite
on passe la brosse coco
et est-ce que tu es ou déjà
donc là c'est un produit
de la montre à moi ça et est-ce que
alors premièrement on passe le balai
tiens la poussière quand la fine passe
balai ou passe autant acoustique avec un
chiffon qu'on a fini passe le chiffon le
langoustique ou la sécher après ou
brosse avec la poisse coco et quand on a
fait une brosser avec la poisse coco ou
face
sur les pieds et puis la brosse en tout
cas là vraiment
[Musique]
le plancher du salon et les bandeaux de
la cuisine c'est à partir de là nous l'a
fait la rénovation nous l'a mis en
bardage et le bonnes couleurs choisies
à l'école il passait devant mais habiter
ici à petite île mais aller à l'école
mais passer devant cette maison là et me
voyez la maison elle était occupé et un
certain moment elle était pas occupée
c'est à partir de là nous l'a eu un coup
de foudre on l'a vu cette que nous
l'acheter en 98
depuis 2002 tu es vraiment pas le pur de
hasards
aujourd'hui mais ça fait un petit
regagne morue un petit grain
mais ça va on a trouvé on a trouvé
magnifique trésor le long Costic et un
gaz mais il est pas fini moi
[Musique]
trésor m'apprendre ma beauté ma pote est
loquée à mon moment
ça me soulier oui mon cœur t'aime
beaucoup